المحتلون يسحبون قواتهم
في شمال بلادنا ، يكون
الانسحاب بطيئًا ولكن ملحوظًا في
مكان ما يتم طردهم فيه بالمعارك في
مكان ما يتركون مواقعهم
بمفردهم ، ونحن نتحرك قدمًا
بحذر ويجب على كل من يعود إلى
هذه المنطقة أيضًا أن يكون حريصًا جدًا.
لا يزال من المستحيل العودة إلى
الحياة الطبيعية كما كان الحال
حتى في المناطق التي عدنا إليها بعد
القتال ، سيتعين عليك
الانتظار حتى يتم تطهير أرضنا ،
انتظر حتى تتأكد من أن
القصف الجديد مستحيل في
شرق بلدنا.  لا يزال الوضع
صعبًا
، حيث يتم تكديس الجيوش الروسية
في دونباس في اتجاه خاركيف ،
فهم يستعدون لضربات قوية جديدة ،
ونحن نستعد لدفاع أكثر نشاطًا
في اليوم الذي أعلنت فيه روسيا أنها ستقلل
بشكل كبير النشاط العسكري
حول كييف وتشرنيف ، كما أقتبس.
في الشهر قالوا
ذلك لحظة عندما بدأت القوات الأوكرانية
أه بدفعهم بنجاح ب
ack من
قرى وبلدات صغيرة بالقرب من
كييف ، لذا فإن السبب وراء قولهم هو
أنهم شعروا بأنهم لا يستطيعون
تحمل الضغط ، ولا يمكنهم الحفاظ على خط المواجهة
حول كييف روسيا التي ردت
منذ لحظات على غارة جوية مزعومة من قبل
مروحيات أوكرانية على مستودع للوقود
وهذا في روسيا ، هذا في
مدينة بلغراد بجنوب روسيا ،
يقول الروس إن هذا قد يكون
له تأثير سلبي على المفاوضات ،
وقالت وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية
لشبكة CNN إنه ليس لديها معلومات عن الحادث الذي انضم إلينا الآن كيمبرلي دوزير محلل الشؤون العالمية و
التايم في مجلة تايم أه
هذا يعني أنه نوع من أن أكون
صريحًا عندما استيقظت على هذا الفيديو وأنا
أرى هذه المروحيات الأوكرانية التي
نعتقد أنها تخرج مستودعًا للوقود داخل
روسيا وهو في الواقع أحد
أسوأ كوابيس إدارة بايدن
لأنه كلما زاد الأمر  القوات الأوكرانية
تقاوم لذا ما لدينا هنا هو
أنهم أتوا من هنا إلى
بلغراد وإذا نظرنا
على خريطة مكان وجود القوات الروسية ،
يمكنك أن ترى سبب قيام بلغراد والوقود
هناك بتزويد جميع القوات في
هذه المنطقة ،
لذلك بالطبع يريد الجيش الأوكراني
عزلهم عن المشكلة
لأن الأوكرانيين كانوا يفعلون ذلك
بشكل جيد و  إن الجيش الروسي في
موقف ضعيف ، والقلق هو أن ذلك سوف
يدفع روسيا إلى فعل شيء عنيف ،
الله الذي تعرفه قالته روسيا إذا
شعرت أنها مهددة إلى
أقصى حد عندها ستستخدم
أسلحة نووية تكتيكية وأشياء من هذا القبيل و
نعم ، يريدون إدارة الشراء
أن يتمكن الأوكرانيون من
استعادة الأراضي ولكن لا يذهبون بعيدًا
عنك